[Música]
y ahora es momento de hablar de economía
por ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañera Daniela hablando Daniela
Buenos días de nuevo Hola buenos días
Valentina vamos a iniciar en Colombia
justamente porque desde este fin de
semana millones de empleados van a
trabajar un poco menos por el mismo
salario Pues concretamente el domingo
cuando entra en vigencia el primer tramo
de una reducción de la semana laboral
hoy en día ese máximo 48 horas semanales
pero a una ley aprobada en 2021 por el
congreso de la República ordena reducir
la gradualmente hasta las 42 horas en
los próximos tres años vemos como la
primera disminución es de una hora pasa
de Julio en julio de 2023 pasa 47 y ya
para Julio de 2026 debería estar en 42
horas por semana el Ministerio de
trabajo ha explicado que la medida
Aplica para empleados del sector privado
y que en este caso trabajar menos horas
a la semana no va a implicar una
disminución de los salarios todo al
contrario la remuneración es mayor
porque por menos horas elaboradas se va
a pagar más y eso incide directamente en
las tarifas por horas extra y también
dominicales que serán más caras que hoy
en día bueno Daniela vamos a cambiar de
tema ayer vimos algo que no ocurría en
63 años y es que los actores se unieron
a los guionistas de Hollywood del
sindicato de actores se unieron a esta
huelga que está prácticamente
paralizando las producciones de cine y
de televisión en la industria de
Hollywood las empresas de streaming por
el contrario Pues están repuntando en la
bolsa esto a pesar de del paro Claro que
sí es que a la medianoche comenzó esta
huelga de más de 160.000 actores que se
unieron a los guionistas Ellos están
exigiendo entre otras cosas mejores
compensaciones también garantías de que
la Inteligencia artificial no va a hacer
su trabajo en un futuro paradójicamente
al cierre de las operaciones en Wall
Street de ayer jueves las firmas
involucradas en las negociaciones
cerraron con ganancias comenzamos con
Netflix que es el líder de servicio de
streaming que cerró el jueves con un
avance superior al 1% concretamente uno
coma cuatro por ciento también Amazon
repuntó él es el dueño de la plataforma
Amazon Prime video que estuvo a poco de
tocar un 3% Disney cuyos y yo agregó de
que la huelga traerá menos enormes
consecuencias para la industria subió
0,35% y vemos como Paramount también
otro de los líderes de la industria
avanzó uno coma 69% esto es el cierre de
ayer hay que ver también cómo se
comporta en el día de hoy cuando en
realidad es el día en que comienza la
huelga y ni siquiera hablemos de los
impactos que eso va a tener para la
economía californiana de Los Ángeles
específicamente Daniela nos vamos a
enfrentar usted y yo como se enfrentan
Estados Unidos y la comisión Europea y
es por las aceitunas porque a mí me
encantan y usted las odia Qué es lo que
está pasando entre Estados Unidos y la
claro ellos también están enfrentados
porque el bloque comunitario de
comunitario decidió hoy volver a llevar
a Estados Unidos ante la Organización
Mundial del Comercio por no haber
eliminado el arancel del 35% a la
aceituna negra española desde el 2018
Estados Unidos está imponiendo este
arancel esto es una medida contra la que
ya falló la omc en 2021 la Casa Blanca
se había comprometido entonces con la
Unión Europea que iba a adecuar su
legislación antes del 14 de enero de
2023 para cumplir con este fallo y
quitar ese arancel sin embargo en
septiembre pasado una nueva sentencia en
Estados Unidos a favor de la imposición
de este arancel volvió a cuestionar las
ayudas a la agricultura de la Unión
Europea Y decidieron mantener este
impuesto de todas maneras como el
impuesto sigue en pie la comisión
amenazó con llevar a cabo contra medidas
si es que Washington sigue incumpliendo
las decisiones de la OMS y las
contramedidas por lo general son que le
imponen una aran algún producto de
Estados Unidos vamos a hacer a ver en un
futuro Pues cuál sea sí tenemos que
estar pendientes porque reitero mi amor
por las aceitunas Así que vamos a estar
pendientes de este tema Daniela
cambiamos a San Francisco va a
desaparecer una icónica cerveza del
mercado pues se llama en y tiene 127
años de antigüedad y acaba de anunciar
que va a cerrar y liquidará después de
años de disminución de las ventas debido
a las difíciles condiciones económicas
esta empresa fue pionera en Estados
Unidos elaboraba cervezas artesanales
con estilo mexicano en la década de 1970
pero hoy los cerveceros en general se
han enfrentado a una dificultad cada vez
mayor para obtener ganancias esto debido
a la proliferación de cócteles enlatados
también de bebidas artesanales licores
ovinos y todo esto redujo las ventas de
cerveza a todo esto se sumó la pandemia
ahora los clientes de incorrubing se
apresuraron a de lo que queda lo poco
que queda del inventario que va a ser
distribuido hasta que se agote
escuchemos lo que piensan algunos de
ellos
he estado viniendo aquí bebiendo durante
más de 30 años
si hay una banderada de la cerveza Este
era el lugar y desafortunadamente se fue
al infierno corporativo
estoy muy triste soy de San Francisco y
he bebido esta cerveza desde que tengo
memoria es una de mis favoritas es como
perder a un viejo amigo como perder a un
viejo amigo Daniela vamos con Los
indicadores económicos de la jornada
pues hubo Street abrió al alza después
de que tres de los más grandes bancos de
Estados Unidos entregarán sus informes
financieros correspondientes al primer
semestre de 2023 JP Morgan y Wells Fargo
tuvieron alzas trimestrales en sus
ganancias del 67% y el 57%
respectivamente 7 grupo también tuvo un
resultado mejor de lo esperado y vamos a
esperar la próxima semana también a que
salgan los resultados de las otras
compañías las acciones europeas operaron
en silencio este viernes pero están en
camino de registrar su mayor salto
porcentual semanal en más de tres meses
todo por esta esperanza de que la
reducción de la inflación en Estados
Unidos le permita la reserva Federal
pausar pronto las subidas de tipos de
interés cerramos con bolsas asiáticas
que estuvieron mixtas en la jornada allí
la expectativa recae sobre china que va
a publicar el lunes una actualización
sobre su crecimiento económico en el
segundo trimestre del año y sin duda
estaremos muy pendientes Daniela Muchas
gracias por esta ampliación Bueno aquí
nos vemos pronto vale feliz descanso Así
mismo así